I forgot to do something.
She gone.
Hello, Hello!
Hello!
Are you monetized yet?
What do you...
Does it look like I'm monetized yet?
Hello!
I think, uh...
doesn't like me that's okay though I don't know why you guys
are so like get get monetized get monetized it happens when
it happens you guys it happens when it happens no worries
welcome to Shinkansen zero Shinkansen yeah this is
Shinkansen zero headed to Tokyo.
That's what it says up there.
I can read.
Futurama meme.
Yeah.
Cha-ching, cha-ching, cha-ching.
Get monetized, get monetized.
Cha-ching, cha-ching, get monetized.
Cha-ching, cha-ching.
I haven't seen this Chilla's art game yet.
Neither have I just know a little bit about it like I know
also there's an easy mode if you make a mistake you will go
back by one car number will not be reset okay I didn't
realize there's an easy mode and my easy mode oh oh I forgot
to turn on the sound notifications for don't knows thank you
guys for the don't knows give me one second you're pretty
pretty pretty good better better alert box
Not the McDonald's jingle.
Don't sue me.
McDonald's.
Ah, thank you.
Okay.
Since you're such a train otaku, can we get a train sim
stream soon?
Oh my gosh.
I want to, I think otaku is a hard, is like a dramatic, you
know, I like trains.
Um, but to say that I'm a train otaku is, I think, greatly
over-exaggerating how much I know about trains.
Because I, uh, um, I just like to ride them.
Test, thank you!
Here's some bucks until monetization happens.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
train simp yeah i just like to really ride trains so thank
you guys thank you can you even hear it can you hear the
notice i guess they don't have to be too loud as long as i
hear it right i don't know much about jp trains but is this
the type of train that donna burke voices yes yes she um
donna burke uh the one of the singers of metal gear and the
voice of the droid she also is the voice on the shinkansen
oh one of the voices i can't i oh gosh nozomi hikari all of
them i don't remember but she is the english voice for the
shinkansen so if you take the shinkansen the bullet train in
japan you will hear her yeah i did not know that cool yeah
it's so cool right i rode the nozomi and heard her there you
go there you go i haven't i've ridden the shinkansen a
couple times before not many times i i say couple like maybe
four like one like like two times so it'll be going there
and back so four times total um but it was before i played
metal gear so i never even realized that it was her Thank
you guys, thank you!
Thank you again for the short karaoke stream yesterday.
I was happy to pull out my King Blades for you.
Thank you.
The train in this game is voiced by Chris Pry.
Ah, man, I knew it!
I knew it!
BMG, before Metal Gear.
We'll build our own mint voice train soon.
I don't even know what they say.
is bound for Nagoya I know I know more what they say on the
normal trains what did they say the doors on the right side
will open what have I said it like really crazy though this
train is headed to Tokyo you can get off whenever you want
in between then, I guess.
The next stop is Shinagawa, maybe.
Are you sure you don't want to go to Akihabara?
Oh, oh, sorry, we're already here.
The doors are opening.
Get out, get out, get out.
Sorry, I didn't buy a ticket.
Get out, get out.
Stepped out of moving train.
Uh-oh.
Akiba sucks now.
What the?
I'm putting you in timeout.
How dare you say that in my chat?
Akihabara does not suck now?
How dare you say?
How dare?
How dare you?
We have a Ikibukuro believer over here.
We have...
who's just like oh yeah go to go to sunshine city it's so
much better thank you fun fact Anna Burke also does the
English audio for the 2020 Olympic Stadium tour the Tokyo
National Stadium oh really I guess I'll have to go I um she
does something else it's her in Nanoha right I'll remember
oh my gosh you guys thank you Oh my gosh.
So many stabs!
I mean, I can finally catch a live stream.
I never got to say welcome back.
So welcome back.
Thank you so much.
Our next stop is Tuesday.
The next station is Yurei Machi.
The ghost town.
For real.
This game is one of those games where you have like the
anomalies that you have to spot.
Um, right?
pretty sure that's all you do and you try to escape the
train is what I imagine I kind of like the ones where you
have to find the anomalies I actually really like hidden
object games and things like that so um these kind of
scratch like a certain itch that I really enjoy like
observation duty I think so I think so is this like the exit
game I'm pretty sure, but, but, um, but on a train.
Mm-mm-mm.
Were you an I-spy book enjoyer when you were young?
Absolutely.
Oh my gosh.
You just, oh my gosh.
You just unlocked a memory for me.
I, uh, another children's game that I would play all the
time was the I-spy spooky mansion.
Like I own, I didn't own any of the other I-spy games on the
computer.
I only owned the spooky the haunted mansion one and I really
liked when the skeleton would crawl around it was so fun oh
my gosh maybe I can find a way to stream that one too I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to like buy a windows 95
computer or something to be able to run these games
hmm I didn't have the book I only had the game, the computer
game.
But it was so fun.
It was so fun.
It's so awesome.
So thank you for unlocking that memory.
Actually, there was like at the end of the game when you
beat it, like the skeleton, I think he would like crawl out
of the chimney.
And I always loved that part.
The spooky skeleton host was cool.
Yeah, he would be in every puzzle.
So fun.
horror edutainment I loved I I'm telling you I don't think
I've changed much from when I was a kid I've always loved
horror so much I've always been like this where if something
was like spooky themed I'd be like that's my favorite
Halloween was the best time ever for me especially because
my parents would get really into it too my dad loved
decorating the house and um there was even like some some
special halloween decorations that he like created himself
and then even when i got older um him and our neighbor uh
the neighbor they would like at the neighbor's house they
would help my dad would help the neighbor set up a haunted
mansion in the neighbor's house for like kids to go through
and stuff as a kid um well i wasn't really a kid at that
time but so uh yeah i just had a family that also loved um
halloween so maybe that also influenced me i don't know i
don't really know i'm just i'm just not like other other
ghosts i like halloween okay new game yeah i haven't started
at all so i there's nothing to over...
Over...
Save.
Whatever the word is.
Whoa, the sensitivity on this is kind of insane.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Settings of sensitivity.
Let's put it down like here.
Let's do crosshair also so you guys can see what I'm looking
at.
Okay.
Where's the crosshair?
Never mind.
That was volume?
No, are you kidding me?
Oh.
I thought I...
It's so funny because even after I changed it, I was like,
that's much better.
Okay, that's action.
That's better.
I...
I, uh, what's, I, uh, placebo affected myself.
Oh, that's funny.
Okay.
Ooh, oh.
Oh, nothing.
Grandma!
Why does this look so strange?
Why does this look?
Why does she look just AI generated or something?
Mm-hmm.
Hey, it's Matara.
Hey, don't say that.
What's the rules?
Hey, Mint, I'm going to Japan around Halloween, and I'd love
to see an idol show while I'm there.
Any recommendations for beginners?
Oh, gosh.
Halloween is, like, such an awesome time to go, because
there's so many...
Oh, who's in there?
There's so many shows going on.
It's harder to say, only because I feel like you should...
Ah!
There's the crosshairs.
It's easier to know the idol group and...
Um...
And like, find them that way.
You know?
Thank you.
Perhaps you'll be interested in playing short horror games
from Ich-Icho someday.
There's a couple of really good ones.
Yeah, yeah.
For sure, for sure, for sure.
Maybe we can do like, um, like a group of, like, short
horror games, kind of, like, play, like, I don't know, three
or four or something in a stream.
Mm-hmm.
Um, okay.
I can't see where I'm clicking.
This way, right?
Oh.
Wait, what if I try opening this one?
Oh, my bad.
open I can't tell is there a crosshair or not I'm not crazy
right I can't tell where I'm clicking I'm just curious oh
this home alone kid oh my god what is this ad on the train
sorry my my don't know sound scared me okay here we go oh
turn back if There is an anomaly.
Speaking of itch.io horror games, I would die of happiness
if you played Voices of the Void.
Never heard of...
Oh my god!
Cat Cafe!
You guys, I'm gonna be honest.
Cat cafes?
I went to a couple while I was in Japan.
And they're just not worth it.
Even, like, it never scratched that itch that I had of
wanting cat time.
And usually the cats are like, are so uninterested because
they're messed with all the time.
You know what I mean?
So it's just, there is one that I like to go to called Neco
Jalala in Akihabara.
It's kind of like off the path.
So it's good.
Is that a person?
Oh no.
Oh, there's an anomaly.
Turn back.
So I go here.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
Hmm?
People aren't anomalies.
Uh, you say that.
They are to me.
To be fair, that's how owning a cat is, too, most of the
time.
I don't...
No, my cat is very...
Can I crouch?
No.
Can I run?
I...
Uh-oh.
You could run.
Okay.
I'm a salary man.
Oh my God, this guy is balding.
Oh, he kind of looks like broccoli.
Hey, wake up.
Are you an anomaly?
Sorry.
I'm afraid to click on him.
Are you?
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Run, run, run.
He's gonna chase us.
Oh my God, he's chasing us!
Okay, are there anomalies in here too or...
Wait!
Is that suitcase supposed to be there?
Ah!
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Why are you looking at me, kid?
Is your mom okay?
Why are you looking at me?
I can't tell if the game has started or not.
We're still at 7!
Am I doing...
Am I playing the game correctly?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, I thought he got up.
Talk to the kid.
I tried clicking on him.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, here, here, here.
Okay.
Oh, God.
I don't even get to go because I'm too...
jumpy, you guys.
Hold on.
I had some coffee earlier.
I think it's making me a little...
Hold on.
I'm going to keep eating my Goku Reese's Puff cereal.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
I'm so sorry.
I'm a little jumpy because of the caffeine, I think.
I've heard they don't even serve real cat at a cat cafe.
It's some kind of mock cat.
Stop!
How dare you!
That kid was staring at an anomaly.
Would you be interested in playing Lifeline?
It's a voice-controlled horror game.
Clippers would go mad.
Oh!
That sounds fun.
Yeah, I'd totally be interested in that.
Today we learned that kids scare the ectoplasm out of
ghosts.
I'm just, you know...
Walking between cards.
I'm being a menace.
Wait.
Wait, looping?
Oh, sorry, I should be reading this.
I think I'm walking a little bit of it.
I'm super excited.
I was really bored here because my sister's not waking up.
Oh, I wonder why.
No matter how long I wait.
But now that I have you to play the game, I feel better.
So he's looping also.
Do you know the rules of the game?
I don't know.
The rules are simple.
See something off in the train?
Turn back.
You know, maybe you should subtitle the whole thing so I
know, you know, that you're not going to keep talking.
Want to finish the game?
Get to car zero and hit the brakes in the conductor's room.
That explains that.
There are no anomalies in the restroom.
That sounds fake.
Why can I open the door then?
anomalies in the restroom area.
Why can I open the door?
And why is it in green?
Kind of sus.
Got it?
Yes, I got it.
Good.
I'm not dealing with an idiot.
Yo kata.
I'll see you at the end then.
The end of the world or...
Okay, kid.
And to you too, little lady.
I like her dress.
Looks like something I would wear, actually.
Hmm.
But what if it, like, opens, you know?
I don't know.
Oh.
Eh?
Isn't this the same as before?
Huh?
Mr. Oh!
I'm scared to talk to him.
Now it starts.
So, what kind of thing would count as an anomaly?
Like...
Um...
What are they still here?
I wonder.
Oh, gosh.
Looks like an anomaly.
Ah!
Wait, is he...
The kid turned into the blob!
The kid turned into a lump of flesh!
Wait, is this an anomaly or...
Hello?
Is that a person?
Hey kid, are you okay up there?
This is the... okay, this is... okay, you know how Tickets
are getting more and more expensive for places and now these
tickets cost the same as like a business class and this is
like the economy.
sticking people wherever they can to make a profit so this
is actually our future right here you guys i think i should
turn around
i think that's an anomaly and so now we'll say six right oh
yippee okay cat cafe head into tokyo very good let's see
Well, it's a good thing we noticed the flesh thing, whatever
that was up there.
Um, oh, I'm scared.
Numbers are counting.
Seven?
Seven!
Maybe I'm tripping.
Okay, it's back to being a suitcase.
A sister is still asleep.
Uh...
Uh, nurse.
I don't know how much of this I need to remember.
Oh, gosh.
Look everywhere.
Okay.
The numbers are numbering.
Yes.
He got folded like an omelette.
The...
Okay, I think the game...
I think it's just the game doing that.
These look... Everything looks normal.
Anything under the seats?
Anyone forget a soda in the seats or anything?
This guy's still got his shoes.
Oh!
Oh, never mind.
Hello?
Oh, he's awake!
Is he?
Actually, I can't tell.
Are you?
Okay.
I think we're good.
Take his shoes.
then it won't be an anomaly what how will we know if it's an
anomaly or not if we take his shoes
one last look of things i don't see anything in the windows
like if there's a creature following me i don't know if
that's a thing either we continue onward no anomaly in this
area okay if you if you say so i don't believe you What?
What did I miss?
No way!
It looked so normal.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We just started.
I don't care.
It's fine.
Check the windows.
I have been looking.
Like, do I have to check each window individually?
Hmm.
Hmm, it's so quiet, the ambience scares me.
Um, this is a suitcase and...
She's gone!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Come up!
Ah!
Six!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we're going to Tokyo!
Okay.
Hmm.
He's still got his shoes.
Everything seems okay.
The seats are proper.
Oh!
Wait!
What's so funny?
Yeah!
Okay, she's here!
She's here, she's here.
I'm scared Headed to Tokyo I don't know like how small the
details will be Like these Sometimes it's hard to say with
these observation games Because sometimes they're like You
need to know Did I hear a footstep?
No I didn't hear a footstep right Oh Oh Oh Okay, let's look
at the windows.
Look at my strut.
Oh, I'm stuck on something.
Oh, it looks normal, but it looked normal before, too.
I don't know why I'm so impressed that He is also in this
reflection as well.
Maybe because, I don't know.
It's just, like, a small detail that I didn't think they
would pay attention to.
I don't know.
I think we're good, you guys.
I think we're good to move forward.
Right?
Yeah, there she is.
She's still asleep.
Hmm.
Reflections.
I've been looking.
Do I have to go down the whole thing?
Look at me.
I look like I'm so vain, like I just love looking at my
reflection.
Like, why am I posing for the camera?
Yeah, it looks normal.
Yeah!
Tokyo!
Tokyo Calling!
Five!
It looks a little darker.
Is it just me?
Heading to Tokyo.
Do you guys know that song?
Tokyo Calling by Atarashi Gakko.
Hello, mister.
Just making sure you're okay.
It looks darker here, right?
It definitely looks darker right there.
Maybe that's the anomaly.
I do, I was obsessed with it for like a week.
Yeah, it's so good.
When is it the game being the game?
And when is it...
Oh, she's here.
No, I think maybe it isn't darker.
imagination.
Ah!
Fly!
Shinkansen Zero headed to Tokyo!
One day, what if it says headed to hell?
I feel like one of the anomalies has to be that, right?
I also have a question.
is this a game where it's always random or is it a game
where each level is always the same because i know with some
of these you have to like play them over and over again to
see all the different kinds of anomalies oh it is random
cool cool
oh i'm too afraid to get close to him i'm afraid of people
okay So now we have to make a one, we have to make a lap up
and down to make sure there's no seat people.
What if he grabbed, what if he grabbed me?
Okay, all right, all right, and let's look this way.
We're looking at the reflections, too.
We're making sure there's no one here.
Looking at the reflections and the chairs.
Okay.
Hello, Mr. Hope you're doing well.
Just stay right there.
Looks like almost Ronald McDonald was in the seat.
Was it that?
The guy sitting there last time?
I think we're good.
I think we are okay to move on.
It always feels weirder that there's no anomalies than there
being an anomaly.
You know what I mean?
Hmm.
Let's go.
Was that flickering meaning that I messed up?
Am I gonna have to hide in the bathroom at some point?
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, headed to Tokyo!
Alrighty!
Very good, very good, very good, very good.
I like psyched myself out.
I'm like, what if he's gonna lunge at me?
What if he's- what if I want to- Chew!
The anomaly is there's a cute ghost on this train.
Where?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Okay, she's here.
Alright.
There has to be something here, though.
There's gotta be something.
Behind me!
What's behind me?
Where?
Under there.
Under where?
Okay, let's start here.
I think it's the issues.
I don't know what all kind of anomalies we can get.
You know?
Shoes still on.
Suitcase.
It's better not to bring, like, your suitcase, though.
on because you know it takes up a lot of space.
That's not such a big one.
I mean you can always store it above too.
.
I don't know, you guys.
I think this one looks good, too.
Do they serve food on these trains?
Usually, yeah.
But, like, it's not, like, you have to buy it.
It's not, like, international flight or sometimes when they
give you food.
Suitcase missing?
No, it's up there.
Someone said one of the lights was flashing.
Is that true?
Or was that just the game being silly?
I'll check again.
Was that the game?
I can't tell if the light adjusting is the game or...
Let's see.
Okay.
Like I'm...
Getting through these seats.
My God.
See you like that!
See you like...
Okay, flashing light, maybe.
I don't know what that would even mean.
Okay, okay.
I think we're good.
I think I'm being a little paranoid, but...
Well, it's fine.
Oh, God!
Jeez!
Okay.
Alright.
This says no anomalies in this area, but I don't believe it.
Oh!
I think I see the anomaly.
Why is she get to sit down, but he's standing up?
Also, he's huge!
He's ginormous!
Do you think he'll come at me?
Is she looking at me?
No.
Can't tell.
Go say hi.
It looks like the inside of a plane.
He eats his broccoli every day.
They need to clean the middle of the cart a little bit
better.
No,
she looks the same as before, I think.
She's still like moving her head around.
I'm scared.
Is he gonna come after me?
I don't want to lose.
You guys were on cart, too!
We're so close!
Look out the window.
Well, it's just normal.
It's just me.
Oh my god, you can see him standing there, though.
This guy is an absolute unit.
His torso is so long!
Wait, how tall are we?
Okay, I don't want him to come after me, but I want to
compare our heights.
I have a bit of a complex, okay?
Armstrong, real.
Don't turn around!
Don't do it!
His torso is so long!
I just want to see what he looks like, you know?
Don't look at me.
He's got boobs.
Oh my god.
My curiosity has been satiated.
One, baby!
Yippee!
This is Shinkansen Zero headed to Tokyo!
See, don't you feel more comfortable sitting and relaxing
and...
Mm-hmm.
that looks like a suitcase let's get to the end of the cart
and assess before we do anything else any other people that
I might have missed okay suitcase is normal sister is there
sleep no one there no one there nurse doctor okay he doesn't
look that tall when he's sitting down um maybe he has like
heels on or something
don't they make those kinds of gosh those like they don't
they make some shoes for guys that like don't look like
heels but actually are just to give them a couple a little
boost maybe why no maybe maybe i'm just i don't know
something looked off Maybe I'm wrong.
Platform shoes?
I don't know if they're exactly platform shoes, but...
The Tom Cruise special.
How tall is Tom Cruise?
I feel very short on this.
Like my character.
Wait, this looks normal, you guys.
You guys, this looks normal.
What do we do?
Hmm.
It looks too normal.
average the numbers what do they mean they're there oh yeah
i see this one's kind of flat oh wait the no the lights
weren't acting like this before were they or am i just crazy
i can't do like if they were like that before or not okay
check the reflection.
I'm checking my reflection.
There were no other people in the sea.
It's right.
I didn't miss it.
I didn't miss anyone, right?
The strut.
I know.
Look at me.
Go.
I
look like I'm such a child.
I didn't pay attention at all, but I'm just gonna believe.
I can't tell if they were playing like this before oh look
at that package area things like this okay headed for Tokyo
yes everything else looks right cat cafe okay I'm getting
paranoid I'm right I don't know I don't know what else could
be wrong looks normal I think I think it is you guys I think
this is a plain Jane train.
Alrighty.
No turning back.
No way.
Headed to Tokyo?
We did it?
Did I beat the game?
Hey, kid.
Um.
Are we okay?
Everybody?
That didn't scare us at all, did it?
We were fine.
We were totally whatever.
Wait, do I need to turn back on this one?
Are there anomalies here?
It doesn't say if there's an anomaly turned back.
Song suggestions, I think you'd slay at.
Oh, I do know melodies of life.
I'll check it out, thank you.
I've been able to catch many streams due to work.
It's okay, I've only done like three.
Congrats on another episode of the podcast.
Thank you so much, thank you.
Good luck with work!
Wait, so I can just go forward here?
Just go forward?
Okay.
What's happening?
What's going on?
Children?
Where's going?
What's happening?
Where?
What's going on?
What's happening?
We stopped momentarily due to an injury.
Oh.
There is no plan for the train to stop at this moment.
Wait, what do you mean?
Please excuse the delay.
Attention, please.
Oh.
We have stopped the momentary due to one injury.
There is no plan for the train to stop at this moment.
Please excuse the delay.
Thank you.
Wait.
was it you
please excuse the delay wait where the injury oh
oh I just go inside okay just kidding one second
one second
oh clear Clear blue car.
Oh, wait.
What do you mean?
Clear blue car.
What do you mean by that?
Ah!
Why did you...
Did you wash your hands?
Mr. Looks like you made it!
Oh, doctor.
Why did she translate this?
You thought this was the conductor's room?
Oh no, your prince, this isn't another castle!
You're only halfway there!
It's the green one.
I never specified which car zero you have to get to.
Don't you know, Shinkansen's have green car?
You know, where the premium seats are?
That's literally what I talked about.
The greens cars.
If you're an adult, you should know that.
You have to go through the green cars to get to the
conductor's room.
What he says versus what is written here is so funny.
The way he has such confidence in English, but he was just
like, my explanation might have been kind of bad.
But here he's just like, duh.
The confidence they give him is so funny.
Whoa, what's that?
Why is there a spaghetti?
I mean, pukam pukam pukam pukam pukam
Oh Whoopsie We have stopped the train due to an injury a
passenger has suffered shattered eardrums due to
high-pitched screaming I'm sorry.
I'm sorry Oh, by the way Oh, sorry I didn't I was listening
on the green car oh when you find an up an anomaly go
forward instead of walking back
what what do you mean there's an abac and then it will come
what do you mean one more thing if you make three mistakes
the ghost will get you
Um...
Why is the subtitles, like, not synced with what he's
saying?
Hey, Mr. Have you ever wondered why we're here?
Never mind.
What is he saying?
He was just kind of like...
He said basically the same thing as the... as the line
afterward.
Mmm, just to suffer.
I don't know who did the translation, but it's just kind of
weird that like when he talks, it's like a little slightly
off.
Let's just clear the game first.
See you at Car Zero.
Wait, so we have to go to...
I wonder if my sister's awake.
Oh,
no, we don't need him to explain the rules.
Okay.
Wait, so okay, if we make three mistakes, then...
Turn back if no anomaly.
Wait, no!
Oh, yes, if there's an anomaly, we keep going.
What?
Who was that that just sat down?
How do I know if that's an anomaly or not?
I don't know.
Why is she coming towards me?
Lady, stay back!
Stay back, I told you!
Can I get through or...
Can I get a sandwich or...
Hello?
Okay.
It's really dark right there where the guys...
Ah, down!
It's dark!
It's dark and scary!
She's working.
We love... We love a business-oriented woman.
It's really dark right there!
I don't like it!
She's gaming.
She's hacking.
I don't like it!
Is it supposed to be this dark?
Why is it so dark?
I think the lights are actually out.
I think that's an anomaly, right?
Anomaly is forward.
So I have to go past him.
I have to go past him.
I have to go past.
This is normal.
It is.
The first car is okay.
Okay.
This is just showing me what's normal.
Are you sure that's normal?
Thank you.
I thought you weren't afraid of no ghost.
I said just a little.
Wait, is that the ghost that will get us if we make the
mistakes?
Help him out.
I'll give you a little lift.
Here, let me just, uh, tuck my hands under your tushy.
Lift!
Wow, these seats are so nice.
Okay.
The ghost, this is, I'm not making a mistake, am I?
Wait, oh wait, turn back if no and um...
Wait, so I go this way, right?
Wait.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, it's confusing.
Okay.
I don't like it, I don't like it, I don't like it.
I can't tell
if you guys are, if you guys are trolling me or not.
This is normal.
I give the Terminator up in here, for real.
Then think for yourself.
No, I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you.
No anomaly in this area.
What the hell did I miss?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I missed a shot!
Uh-oh.
Uh oh.
The ghost is gonna get me.
Oh.
Oh, you didn't miss anything?
Okay, okay.
Thank you!
What do you got?
What are you blind?
Damn.
Her...
Her waist?
Damn!
Damn, girl.
I'll buy whatever you're selling.
Give me them almonds.
Oh, yeah!
Her waist is an anomaly.
Also, oh, her toes her toes are really out.
She's, like, kind of floating.
That's okay, though.
She's got them...
Them healies.
Okay.
Oh.
That seems to be an anomaly.
Are you actually spying on me?
Oh my god, she did hack me.
She hacked me!
For real!
Why does it look blue on your screen?
Love he...
Right, wait.
Turn back if no.
You're right, right, right, right.
Okay.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, God, what do you want?
Ha!
Are you human?
No.
Uh, I hope so.
You can't trick me.
You're wearing a suit!
It's so in my ear.
That's strange.
You don't act like the others.
That much I can't tell.
He's saying that office workers are not...
Not human.
Office workers don't deserve human rights.
How long have been here for?
Ami?
You?
We don't know.
How long have been here for?
It could be any of us.
How long have been here for any who?
I don't know.
What if?
Oh my gosh.
Here's my game theory.
What if this old man is the one that had the injury, the
accident?
And he is now dead limbo.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
Did you meet anyone in the train?
A boy?
That's a good one.
That's good.
From my observation.
And from my 84 years of experience?
Seems like most people here are not actual humans.
This guy is so close.
This is like how actual old people are, man.
He's giving me that lead stare.
It's good, come on.
The lead-paint stare, please, sir.
They never respond when I talk to them.
They're almost like...
Robots.
I know a human when I see one.
So my conclusion is...
Never trust the men...
In suits.
That lady, she was also wearing a suit.
Now if you'll let me...
Oh.
I'm tired.
Let me just sleep.
He's like acting like we're the men in black or something.
Before I...
Oh.
before you what sir oh wait what happened to his face sir
are you okay oh oh nah he's just asleep
I think we're okay it does say that there's no anomalies in
this area so for him to be in this area means he truly is
not an anomaly ah I'm going to grab a cough drop real quick.
So sorry if you hear it.
I think I need one because of how spooked I'm getting.
Wait, are any of these open?
Oh, yes, this one is.
Okay.
What flavor is it?
It's just...
It's not really any flavor.
menthol cough drop ASMR do you like that do you like hearing
me open my bag and I have like a little baggie of cough
drops or rather the baggie has other bags of cough drops in
it
and then also some packets of yuzu and let it's yuzu wait am
I going the right way yeah wait am I going the right way I
came from...
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
I don't like the way it sits every time.
Mm-hmm.
You can use the phone?
You can?
Oh, I shouldn't turn back, though.
What does that sound?
Okay.
She's doing regular business things.
on her blue screen what if I block you oh okay Wow oh I was
gonna say this is some customer service I don't even have to
use my feet this is the shinkansen zero headed to Tokyo hmm
yeah unstoppable force for real I
don't like this guy I don't like I don't like him, I don't
like him No I'm right, no Turn around Turn around Oh my god,
I don't like this part at all I don't like this part at all
Pride eyes It's Chilla's art Heard that song and took it
personally Every now and then I fall apart And I need you
now tonight I need you more than ever And if you'll only
hold me tight
All these teats have faces on them Oh what?
They kind of look like...
No they don't
What faces?
I don't see anything in the...
What is that, like, bar?
Maybe it's just a reflection of the light.
Oh, it's so...
Wait.
Okay, that's also a reflection.
I thought I saw, like, someone leaning out from a seat.
I think this is normal.
This seems pretty normal.
the back of the seat looks like a robot face oh it does kind
of look like a robot face yeah i see that okay so i have to
run back
wait what's that light right there
is this usually on wait is this in or not wait
These are sea lights?
That's normal?
Okay.
Turn back if no anomaly.
So we're turning back.
What kind of sandwich is this?
Chicken green.
What is chicken and green?
Sea lantern blocks.
Ha ha ha.
didn't the lady have a blue screen on her laptop she did
that's why we're good because it's a blue screen she's
literally doing nothing ma'am ma'am who are you typing to
she's got she's got like the special vision oh my gosh she's
got on google glass we just can't see it and it's that's why
she's typing actually oh she's got them apple goggles
I hope I didn't just make a mistake 25 25 You know what's
funnier than 25 26
No one's in here though all right wait okay okay good wow
thank you for the hakato no thank you so much just want to
say that i appreciate you and to not let the rather negative
messages you've been receiving get to for every bad message
there are 100 of us that love and support you anyway best
luck you're doing great thank you so much thank you
appreciate it so much Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, so far so good.
Ma'am, we'll let you pass.
You shall pass.
Wait a second.
Sticks!
You weren't selling sticks before, were you?
Actually, I think she was.
I can't remember, though.
I can't remember, actually.
Chicken and green.
I feel like if it's...
That looks down there, that looks like a tomato...
Tomato.
Tamago.
An eggy sandwich.
I didn't just say tomato for no reason, it's because I was
thinking tamago.
But...
Oh man, that's how my brain works.
For real, you guys.
My brain can be quite confusing.
Oh, gosh, lady.
Your dumpy is making it hard to pass.
Tomato...
Tomago.
Ah!
Oh!
Gosh, I don't like you!
Wait, didn't he say don't trust the people in suits?
But they're not wearing a suit.
This Shinkansen.
Zero.
Headed.
To Tokyo.
He looks like Orochimaru.
He does actually.
Anime Orochimaru.
Oh wait.
Anime Terminator is what I was thinking.
Wait this one looks too normal too.
He's come back.
Is that work?
I'm afraid that I'm going to miss something because it's in
the dark area and I don't want to go over there.
I'm afraid of the dark you got.
Did the cushions always look like this or am I going crazy?
Paki.
Did the cushions on...
They did?
Okay.
No and yes.
Why are you like this?
Is it normal then?
Are we normal?
Is everything normal?
Nothing's normal about this.
But is it normal?
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
My throat is actually starting to hurt.
I need to stop screaming.
Creamy.
Mr. Mr!
Why is your eye glowing?
Oh!
You can...
Thank you!
I like to think that when the your simp sound plays, it's
you guys calling me a simp, which is quite honestly
accurate, so...
Looks good to me, Kappa.
That, I don't believe that there are two trains in a row
that are normal.
Right?
Like, that doesn't sound good.
I'm being serious here?
Go, I know you can make it.
Get out of here.
Everyone's waiting for you.
the bright blue desktop wallpaper.
I didn't either.
On my computer.
I just...
Well, I technically did.
Well, okay, hold on.
No, I technically didn't, but I'm using wallpaper engine, so
it's fine.
I don't see anything in the reflections.
I think we're good.
Oh, oh, no.
Please, no mistake.
I'm afraid of the ghost.
I'm afraid of the ghost!
There can only be one ghost here, okay?
Where did grandpa go?
25.
Oh my gosh.
There actually was nothing.
Headed to Tokyo.
25.
Back home.
Go off this train.
Need you.
Get out of here.
Is that just the lighting or what is... what is that?
Is that a... what is that?
Is that an anomaly?
Is that a person?
What is that?
Invisible man.
I have to go past it!
Invisible Man Anomaly?
Well, he's not doing a very good job.
I noticed him immediately.
Ma 'am, ma'am, ma'am.
What did I just hear?
Ma'am, ma'am, ma'am, there's a man in my seat.
Please, please, there's a man in my...
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
I thought she responded.
one time okay so I once um though okay so one time I flew
business class back from Japan it was the only it's the only
time I've ever flown business class on it on a flight and I
only did it on the way back home because doing both ways is
would have been so expensive right whoa fancy I know it was
after a work trip so I was like you know what I am gonna get
the business class because I'm I've been working this whole
time and I'm very tired I just really wanted to like feel
good on the plane and I sat down in my little cubicle and
also I was just like this probably will be the only chance I
get at business class because usually they're like full like
I just like to even though I'm not going to get it but
usually all the seats are taken but for this flight they
weren't and so I was just like you know slash the price in
half and my old company had taken care of the initial price
so it almost felt like I was paying for just a regular
ticket to Japan anyway so I was like okay um so I know it's
like sounds like copium but I really had to like do to get
myself to buy this thing um so girl math yeah actually um
the old company being heaven yes yes but anyway so i um i uh
i sat down in my little cubicle and i'm like okay this is so
oh my gosh this is like my first this is a first-time
experience this is so crazy and i lean back in my seat and
to my right is a man's foot the guy behind me like put his
feet up over the cubicle so that his feet were directly in
my face and i was like this is met i did not spend this
money well like but I did I I I I am in I am in the business
class I do not deserve this disrespect so I I called over a
flight attendant and I was like I know we haven't taken off
yet but can you tell him to like put his feet down also I
was like the the beds go down like there's so much foot
space down there why don't you just lay down if you want to
extend your feet like that did you tell him off no because
i'm very non-confrontational but i told the i told this the
flight attendant i was like could you please tell him to
like put his feet down they're in my face and she goes to
him thank you so much um she goes to him and says the girl
in front of you complained could you please um put your feet
down and i was like now you're gonna now you put a target on
my back you couldn't just say hi sir we're about to take off
could you please lower your feet like anything like that no
yeah she put me on blast i was so almost like i thought this
is gonna be the worst trip ever i should have never paid for
it anyway this invisible man for some reason reminded me of
okay we just gotta run forward we just gotta run forward we
just gotta run run run he's probably just gonna stay there
he's he's he's in his own lane he's he's living his
invisible life he doesn't even want to be seen he doesn't
even want to be seen so he wouldn't chase after me because
he doesn't want us to notice him
anyways maybe i should have publicly shamed that man been
like feet are stinky and they're in my face okay moisturized
and unbothered I hope he's not moisturized okay here we go
sorry I know I'm like stalling I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared I'm scared I'm scared Maybe we should have confirmed
that it was an invisible man.
But that thing has never been there before, so.
Oh!
Oh my god, it's beautiful!
Wait, there's nobody here, though.
Wow!
Kind of like...
Oh, that's my feet.
I was like, I like this one.
Wait, we have to continue on through this.
I was going to turn around, but...
We just gotta...
Wait, is that a person up?
No, that's a...
Wait, that's a tree.
No anomalies, just rad.
Well, at least it was easy to tell.
I'm still kind of scared, though.
What if there's, what if a, what if a, what if a, a lion
pops out at me or something?
I don't know.
Okay, run!
Ah!
Hey, it's a kid!
Hey, mister.
Aw, do you think we'll ever get out of here live?
Uh, think about your sister.
Um, well, I'm gonna keep doing my job.
Maybe you should consider doing yours, okay?
Wow.
That is a trunk.
Anybody in here?
I was wondering if we were gonna see him again i thought he
would be like in the bathroom but it's 25 oh 24 gosh it's a
good thing that i that i okay it's a good thing i clicked on
it because i really thought it was 25 oh can we go back to
the pretty car please can we go back to the nice car
well one thing i can be i can feel safe about is that
nothing will come running from that direction because we
have to go forward shouldn't it be 23 wait what do you mean
24 is not as funny as 15 number 15 tomato sandwich Okay,
nothing.
Oh, I thought she was about to look at me.
Nothing in the reflections that I can see.
Hello?
I mean, I could see the mountains from here, though.
Nothing.
Nothing here.
Oh!
I can't tell if it's the game or not.
Help.
Mystery, you need some help.
Thank you.
Glad to have you back, boss.
Any chance you'll play Kojima's masterpiece, Death
Stranding, in its full glory on stream.
I would like to, just because I want to get ready for Death
Stranding 2.
I doesn't feel darker than before.
Why?
Why does I feel darker than before, you guys, you guys!
I know it's not, but I think I'm... I don't know!
An anomaly where he's not balding.
An anomaly he has, like, luscious, beautiful hair.
He's... He looks fine.
he just he's like oh he's just a jolly guy he's he's fine
he's handsome don't don't worry about it i'm i'm on your
side mister i'm not gonna let these people bully you headed
to tokyo am i just getting really lucky with these or what
like wait let me make sure there's no one sitting in these
seats i haven't um um he's got a suit on yeah we can't trust
him but that doesn't mean you know
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna move forward but I'm gonna let you
guys decide okay you guys you guys tell me if there's if
there's if there's anything okay I'm too scared that man is
my spirit animal I'm also bald like he's not bald he's bald
dang.
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared.
Oh!
Okay, forward, forward, forward.
Okay, it's still there.
It's still there.
Okay, thank you guys, thank you.
You really saved me.
Okay, turn back if no anomaly, okay.
Okay.
Good job.
Good job, team.
What would I do without you guys?
Oh.
Oh, God, please.
I need a break.
I just...
Oh, man.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Car one.
This is Shinkansen Zero.
Headed to Tokyo.
Okay.
Good work, boss.
No, that was on you guys.
That was all you.
Oh.
She scared me.
Mm-hmm.
She's still typey town.
Okay.
No one else in these seats.
What are you working on?
She's writing fan fiction.
Probably.
I think that's just the game.
Okay.
All right, guys.
So far so good.
The other one, the other one could have been easy to miss,
though.
You know?
Had I, had I not gone back, so...
This train is so chill.
You, you think this is chill?
Are you feeling really relaxed right now?
Are you having a good time?
I'm so happy for you.
You think this is a nice, chill little run here?
Hmm?
Yeah?
God.
Oh, God.
Okay, Mr. Oh.
Oh.
Wait, I don't see anything for real, though.
Chilla.
Oh gosh, I feel so stressed.
I feel very intense.
I feel like I need, like, a massage after this or something.
She's so tall, too.
How, how, how short are we?
It's okay, though.
I prefer tall women, you know?
It's okay.
Um.
Ghost massage.
Put my...
By the time I'm done, I'm going to be like a little ghost
orb because I'm going to be so relaxed.
I'm going to be...
They're going to need me into a ball.
You guys think it's okay?
I didn't see anything.
oh gosh every time it does that that's that's part of the
game that's that's not like a I think it would be more
obvious if it were like a flickering light you know looks
okay to me turn back if no anomaly I think there's no
anomaly what do you think ma'am Check the old man.
There's no face in his bald spot.
He looks the same as before.
He looks pretty much the same.
He is so tall also.
Gosh, maybe I'm the child.
Okay.
Don't look at me, don't look at me, don't look at me, don't
look at me.
Okay.
Here goes nothing.
24.
22.
The numbers.
What do they mean?
Zero!
Oh my gosh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
Okay.
So far.
So far, so good.
He's always said 22.
What do you mean?
No, I know.
Oh, wait.
He did say 25 before because I said like need you go need
you go off the train.
Yeah He did say 25 before I'm not crazy I'm not crazy Put me
in a room a room full of rats the rats made me crazy I was
crazy once they put me in a room a room full of sticks the
sticks made me crazy But we did skip 23 yeah Unless I just
forgot to...
I forgot to...
Oh.
Crazy cute.
Stop it!
Unless I forgot to check the telephone.
At that point.
Okay.
Where's rule seven?
Rule seven is what you imagine it to be.
Rule seven is, you know, what you make of it.
Mm-hmm.
Ghost of rule seven.
seven.
So far, nothing in the windows, nothing in the seats.
in the streets.
Ghost in the sheets.
Ghost in the seats.
That ghost.
What?
What was that sound?
I don't know.
You'd think I would get used to it, but I'm not.
I just think, what if at some point they're going to grab
me?
No way.
There's no anomaly on this one either.
It's not common for people who have watched other people
play this game.
But there's, like, typically...
More anomaly-less trains than anomaly-filled trains.
No, your luck is ridiculous.
Well, if it grabs you, it would be an anomaly.
So true!
Kyo-mo kawaii, isn't it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This is Shinkansen Zero headed to Tokyo.
Tokyo calling.
Um...
Okay.
If no anomaly turned back...
It would really suck since we're at train zero!
Right?
Right, lady!
She's kind of double-jointed, just like me.
Rule 7 is rule 30... No!
That's not an anomaly, right?
That's just a...
I think that's just a...
how she looks.
Her face is a bit weird.
You, actually, this is maybe the most normal faces I've ever
seen in Chilla's art game.
Like, ever.
Ever, ever, ever, ever.
Like, I think this is actually the most normal faces I've
ever seen in a Chilla's art game.
They even have, like, she has, like, a little bit of, you
know, like, bit of definition like i think in the past
they've just been like pngs pasted on top of a of a of a of
a egg and that was their face yeah true they're improving
yeah yeah she doesn't look so bad like creepy yes and also
she's got like these weird old pixelated shadows but that's
fine that's fine what's her skincare routine for real okay i
think i think I think...
Alright guys, what's the consensus?
Do we...
Do we say there's no anomaly?
I don't see anything.
We went through every seat?
I truly didn't see anything.
I think it's good.
All clear?
I'd say there's none.
Okay.
Still nothing in there.
Alrighty.
Conductors room!
Nice.
Good job, everybody.
Wait, so...
How does this one work?
I still go back if there's an anomaly or...
Or do I just go forward?
She scared me again.
Just go forward now.
Oh, so there is no anomaly.
Just go to the end?
Just go forward?
Oh, madam.
I love to see you walk away.
Headed to Tokyo.
So there's no anomalies here?
I could just go?
Even with her?
With him?
Ghost on bottom left.
I think I'm going to run for it.
Conductor's room.
I can't tell if I should believe you guys.
I'm just going to do a quick sweep.
A quick check.
Just in case.
Just go forward.
Okay, fine.
Fine, fine.
Fine, fine, fine, fine, fine.
Doesn't work.
Wait, what's over here?
It's...
It's a PNG.
I'm putting a break.
I'm putting a stop to this crazy train.
Brrr!
Hmm?
Uh-oh.
Why am I so small?
Wait, we can go out, or we can go through here?
Oh, oh!
Ending one!
Get off the train!
This
song is safe to use on YouTube.
That...
What song?
What
song?
Wait, so what's the other ending?
Wait, what even happened?
Nothing even happened.
Huh?
I What about the kid
This is the normal end Oh wait I got the bad end
Okay Interesting So there's Wouldn't the bad end be dying To
the ghost I do kind of want to see what happens if you mess
up three times But Yay Yay my favorite song yay I I don't
know do I want to play it again I want to play it again I I
feel kind of unfulfilled but I have to go through it all
over again I got really lucky this time where we really
didn't make that many mistakes so but I kind of went really
slow because I was scared continue from the stop oh there's
a checkpoint oh okay okay oh hold uh space key to skip
okay wait so where should I continue from train from the
green train or wait after after stopping the train
thank you that was the bad end you walked into the light you
have to go back okay so after stopping okay okay so here i
go forward right i don't go into the light
i'm scared it's so quiet
what is that wait there's something in the on the oh just
kidding maybe the grandpa or the kidder in here
okay keep going forward okay I am oh wait no wait it's both
vacant and occupied how is that possible oh just kidding was
it like that the whole time the phone is also gone thank you
really don't know thank you don't forget the supporter
content section to see all the vtuber references on one
train car I didn't turn the supporter stuff off so I think I
just didn't see them do I just keep going?
How far do I need to go for?
Schrdinger's bathroom.
Okay.
Just go?
I'm going.
Is there anything in here?
Aji-chang.
Kid in the bathroom.
No one in the bathroom.
I don't even know why I'm going back through here.
All the way back?
Oh.
Was that suitcase there before?
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it.
Ah!
Wow!
Oh!
Choo!
Thank you!
You have to walk all the way back to your seat if you want
to see the supporter stuff.
I think you either choose supporter stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
But is that the only reason you guys are having me walk all
the way back?
Or is it actually the way to get the other ending because...
I'm gonna check the bathroom every time.
Still not there.
I should probably, like, check in these corners, too.
Just in case.
Other ending.
On four.
There were seven, right?
I really have to go all the way back!
Yeah?
Hold on, give me one second.
I'm going to do something.
Let me run real quick.
Na, na, na, na, na.
Okay.
Um.
Meow.
Do I have to check the bathroom every time?
Or, or can I, uh, or can I, um, ignore it?
Yes?
Yes.
So many people.
Some people say yes.
Yes, some people say no.
Why are you checking it even in case the kid is in there,
right?
Always check the bathroom.
Oh, she's awake.
Hello?
Oh, she's like, where's my brother?
Oh, loading.
Okay.
She sounds so cute.
So the train wasn't stopping and it was looping?
Actually, I also just noticed that their mouths move now
too.
Before, like, in old Chilla's art games, they would just,
since it was just the PNG face, like, their mouths wouldn't
really talk, right?
And he managed to hit the brakes and stop everything?
Oh, that's what she just said.
It turned off again.
Everything about this is so hard to believe.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
I guess I have no choice but to believe you.
That is not what she said.
Something doesn't feel right.
I don't remember boarding this train.
Boy in a black hood.
Oh, I saw your brother?
Oh, Naoki!
I was with my brother before I lost my memory.
God, she's so cute.
Did he say anything about why we're here?
Um...
No, you didn't see him?
You weren't with him?
Did you see him on the way here?
Uh, oh, not after I stopped the train.
So you came from the green car side.
Then he must be on the other side.
All right.
Let's find him.
him and get out.
but, oh, wait a Okay.
Why isn't that part subtitled?
If you think about that, then, then, there's another person
coming out of the What do you mean by that?
Come to think of it.
Oh, I guess that's true, yeah.
What about the people who might end up here in the future?
What about the people who might dot, dot, dot.
Just wait a little bit.
Did you guys need subtitles for that one, actually?
Shouldn't we think of a way to end this nightmare for good?
Let's burn it down!
Let's burn the train!
A looping place.
I saw this in an anime.
Come on, girl.
You know what you want to say.
It's just like one of my Japanese anime.
Oh, I remember.
In the show.
What?
They broke the loop by having two people run to the opposite
direction really fast.
Jujutsu Kaisen reference?
Oh, actually?
I only watched season one of Jujutsu Kaisen.
How about that?
Wait.
But the train isn't looping anymore.
Right, the train stops looping after hitting the brakes.
Oh, I know.
What if we start the train at the same time?
Why are we starting the train again?
On both ends.
You can go back to the green car side.
I'll go to the normal car side.
Why is there a...
Wait, I'm confused.
Why would there be a way to start the train on this side?
Huh?
Oh, so I...
And also, we're closer to the normal car side, so you're
having me run all the way back?
No, I'll go to the normal side.
Wait.
Wait, does this affect the ending?
Uh-oh.
Go to the normal side?
Normal or you get the same ending?
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Go to the normal side or you get the same.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Oh, I just saw the other ending is back to your seat and
choose to go to white car.
The supporter stuff is unrelated at the very start of the
game as an anomaly.
Ah, got it, got it, got it.
Understandable.
Thank you.
Okay, so I'll go to the normal side.
Are you sure?
My brother is on the other side.
Can I trust you with my brother?
Yeah, I'm competent.
Well, you did manage to stop the train.
All right then.
I trust you, Mr. Huff-fuff-fuff.
Yeah, all right then.
Let's hurry.
Who knows when the train will start again?
Okay.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, That's your, that's what you said.
Come on.
Get running, girl.
Get running.
Where's the kid?
Oh, what just happened?
Hello?
Oh, it's not even, I don't think it's letting me.
I'm scared.
What's gonna happen?
Is someone gonna chase me?
I swear if you come trying to chase me I'm gonna I'm gonna
do something you're not gonna like it run oh okay I'm
running I'm running I'm running why are they already chasing
after me are they already chasing after me I don't hear
anything though are they like an invisible force chasing
after okay I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm running
I'm running I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running,
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running,
I'm, oh, it's shrinking, it's shrinking, it's shrinking,
it's shrinking, it's shrinking, oh my god, oh, it's still
shrinking, it's still shrinking, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, oh
oh it's crushing it's crushing it's crushing it's crushing
oh my god no no no no no no no no oh my god it's just like
in my nightmares ah Oh
whoa it's beautiful wait we're in the actual normal world we
made it back?
Maybe?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, oh.
Maybe we're not in the normal world.
Actually, I'm not so sure.
Hmm.
I love my void trees.
You know?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Where's the door here?
Oh, I can't go out.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh my god, we made it!
Oh.
Oh...
Oh, sorry.
Oh, Nihisan, you're...
You're okay.
Freaky ghost train.
Oh, Nihisa.
You're okay.
Naoki!
Good day, you're okay.
O 'Nisan, I'm fine now, mister.
You want to come with us?
Oh.
I only have...
No, not yet.
You're right.
It's not your time yet?
Am I dead for real?
What?
I think I know what happened to us.
Wait, so, but they're gonna come back to life, right?
It's okay, Mr. Or they are dead, are they're the dead ones?
I think actually they're the dead ones.
More importantly, We have to get home.
Thank you, Mr. Sayonara.
And goodbye.
Oh my god.
Oh, thanks kid.
Don't go breaking your arm for me.
No, I think they're the dead ones.
I can feel it as a ghost, you know.
I get that sense from them.
Oh!
I fell?
Wait!
Oh!
Remember when the...
remember when the um thank you for the ray thank you so much
remember when we uh had the the train stopped because of the
personal injury you were collapsed on the floor luckily
there was a doctor on board that does not sound real it
seems you were suffering a light form of deep vein
thrombosis.
What?
That's a voice.
Or what the Lemons call it, economy class syndrome.
You guys, I called it from the very beginning that this was
a game about the rich.
They actually did stuff our body up in there.
I can't believe it.
I was right this whole time.
For some reason, I thought we were in the bathroom when I
was like, please do not lay me on the ground in the
bathroom.
Also, are they like on little stools?
I thought they were crouched at first, but it looks like
they have little tiny benches.
Laying down and raising the legs seemed to have helped.
You should be thankful he was here.
It would have taken much longer to get help.
Because the train had also stopped while you were out.
Oh, it, the, she said the personal injury.
Stop because of the personal injury.
What is she, your mom?
Oh, that was the injury.
Okay, wait.
Are we the injury?
Oh, no.
A young woman and a boy were confirmed to be involved in the
accident.
Over.
Oh.
I knew they were dead.
And I was almost dead too.
Because I had to sit in an economy.
Ending to sad reality.
That's why you got hit.
Don't go walking in the middle of the train tracks.
Oh, here's our song.
Ah, economy seats were too uncomfortable.
Look at that guy.
We saw him, right?
We saw him in the first class.
So he literally was making fun of us.
It's always interesting seeing what VTubers are in the
credits.
Maybe one day I will be in the credits.
I know it's, I know I would have to do it myself.
Like I know I have to go to the Patreon, subscribe to the
Patreon.
But maybe I'll do it one day.
I think every time I play one of these games, I say I'll do
it.
And then I forget.
And then I forget completely.
Champs Company Y is on.
One day.
Yeah, one day I will be a supporter too.
I say, like, one day, as if, like, it is this great honor,
even though it's just something I need to do myself.
Okay, next game, guys.
Next Chilla's Art Game.
I'm gonna put my name in the game.
Okay?
I think I belong there because I'm a ghost.
Yeah, you just pay up.
Exactly.
I just have to remember to do it.
though I am thank you deep vein thrombosis means having a
blood clot in your leg veins most often which can happen due
to sitting too much if not treated it can be fatal or cause
loss of limbs oh my gosh wait actually the song is so fine I
like it I saw that there's a way to put yourself like as a
character in the game can you imagine if I was one of the
ghosts Wouldn't that be so fun?
Wouldn't it be so fun if I was chasing after you?
I'm gonna ask her to be like, hey.
Oh, it is?
It was an actual movie.
A sponsor.
Hey.
You were a Rochimaru.
I'm just chilling.
I'm chillas.
I'm chilling in the seat.
That one...
I think um I think actually what happened in this is what
kind of um gets me about these find the find the anomaly
type of game you know what I mean so I love these types of
games but because they're randomized you can get a lot or
you can get a little And so, um, so, yeah, I don't know.
I, I, uh, um, I still liked it.
Just felt like maybe we didn't get some of the more
interesting, some of the more interesting anomalies, maybe.
Like, gotcha.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
But we got pretty lucky in that we could finish it, like,
without much error.
you can continue and find the anomalies that's true that's
true that's true continue supporter you guys really want me
to do the supporter content oh my gosh calm down calm down
oh that's cute though the way that they just have it like
all like just here they're just like it's all just laid out
wait so is there is this is this just uh there's no
anomalies it's just looking at the supporter content i guess
this is a cute way of doing it especially oh my god oh he's
i forgot he was here wait oh they go all the way down
oh i feel like this would make more oh my god so cute i feel
like this would make more sense
called.
Oh, pick things up.
Cute!
Oh my gosh, so cute.
My throat hurts from screaming.
That's so cute.
Oh my gosh, so cute.
You guys, I found out something that made me so sad.
Okay, so I love eating inari sushi.
And I was like, I was like, this is healthy, right?
It's tofu.
I mean, I know it's fried tofu.
but like it's tofu and I googled it and they were like inari
zushi is really not good for you because of the oils and
this and that and this and that and I was like but it's like
it's so delicious healthy it's so oily I never I never
thought of it okay I never thought of it like oh well Oh,
well, I want to see the sandwich.
Oh, never mind.
Helsing game.
Like, Helsing the anime?
I like the train.
Hey, Chilla's Art, put me on the train.
The Edo train.
I can't even read this one.
It's so small.
Ugh.
Get off today!
Oh my gosh, Winter Cedar!
No!
I want to donate while I can.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh, no!
Is there something on the suitcase?
Oh gosh!
She scared me too.
Oh, there is...
Oh my god, there's little chinchillas under the sea!
That's so cute.
I wish I could crouch.
Scary.
Oh.
Ah!
Inoyama Tamaki!
Cute.
I think Tamaki-san has been in like every game ever.
Or every like Chilla's art game that I've seen.
I think he's been in every single one.
For as long as I can remember.
Uh...
Mlaka movies.
making me hungry.
Hot coffee.
This is making me hungry.
Oh cute!
Ronald McDonald.
Ronald McDonald!
Tote mo oishi!
Oh, it's Iris!
Wait, wasn't Ollie in another game?
Wait, this one's so funny.
The way she's, like, squished against the cam.
Iris cider.
Oh, it's a song.
Kiyo.
Naboo, Naboo Bento.
Iris.
It's Iris.
I can't grab it.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
No wonder.
I couldn't.
It's.
It's just like a couple.
They're just bragging.
All that effort just to see a damn couple.
Good for you.
You've missed a few at the start.
I know I'm going to go back.
I mean, that's what...
That's, uh...
That's, I want that exact same type of energy.
If I am in the game.
That's what, that's the kind of picture I'm gonna send in.
Yeah, I'll go back and look at some of the other ones.
Are these Korean VTubers?
A cute vanilla strawberry.
Cute.
This is making me hungry, you guys.
All I had was cereal.
Oh, cute.
Mmm, peach tea.
Lots of bet- lots of people just leaving their garbage
everywhere.
Rainbow ice.
Cute.
Umay drink.
Where did I...
I don't even...
Oh.
What is going on here?
Oh!
Ah!
Um.
Where did I...
Where did I start?
I don't remember.
Oh my god, cute!
Neco.
I think we saw something very cursed.
I think we saw something that we shouldn't have.
Oh, that was the anomaly.
Oh, we saw these ones.
We saw...
Did we see these?
Yeah, yeah.
We saw these.
Did I see this one?
No, cute.
If you guys like guillotan, have you ever had guillotan
before?
Cow tongue.
I'm not such a huge fan.
Are there more cars?
I don't think so.
Actually, I say that.
I have no idea.
Oh, nope.
Oh, where did I go?
I leave off I heard it's good I don't like um really chewy
meat and if you don't like chewy meat you might not like it
either like it the taste is good but like it's super like so
that's why I don't like it Sam yeah oh wow
Work it, girl!
Get your face on the bento.
Hell yeah!
What's so funny?
Latte rich.
Oh, cute!
Cute.
Do people typically go through these?
Is this it?
Is this why you guys wanted me to go through the entire
train?
Is this why you berated me to look through the supporters?
Oh my gosh.
That's really clever actually.
The fact that she's in the salad.
Oh my god.
Oh cute.
There's Ollie somewhere too?
Okay, we'll find her.
Old man.
Frog man.
Quero, quero, bento.
VTuber energy drink.
Would you guys drink a VTuber energy drink?
I mean, we have VTuber potato chips.
I'm surprised there's not...
Oh, wait, we missed one.
Surprised there's not VTuber energy drink.
a frog man.
Couldn't be me.
Shio Daiichi.
Mmm.
Sweet coffee.
Sweet.
I don't know why I couldn't pick up the other.
Oh, this one's cute.
This one's really cute.
Couldn't pick up the other, that blue train, though,
earlier.
Cute.
Oh, it's just Some delicious water, of course.
Gamer.
Gamer Bento.
Mint G Fuel Win.
It's cute.
It's so cute.
There's so many.
Oh my gosh.
No one's gonna find me if they...
If you have to go through all of these.
Mortis.
If I were to get one, no one would find me.
I think, right?
Cute.
I like that design.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Otome Bento.
Oh!
Hidden one.
We won.
You find me?
You won?
Alright.
Cute.
Chocolate.
Oh.
Matcha.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
What's the floor mean?
We're in seat 13.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, gotcha, man.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, Pookie!
I like her art.
She has a webb.
that I read.
That's so funny.
This is the last place I expected to see her.
For free?
What's for free?
Cute.
Looks like a Cinderella girl's, like, card, you know.
Ghost!
Me too.
Oh gosh, that guy scared me again.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
This guy's got nothing.
This is economy class.
All these people affording these bentos, they're crazy.
Fun.
Like the eye patch.
I'm mama.
Cute.
The most dangerous sniper.
The most dangerous bento.
These people just get in there their normal ass faces like
at some reason it's like totally normal to see the vtubers
at this point because vtubers are in like every single one
of these games but seeing like the people just their normal
photo like their facebook pics are just so funny to me i
don't know why it's like it just it's just takes it takes me
out of like the immersion for some reason i don't know why
oops
But...
Paroo!
Paroo, paroo, paroo, paroo.
Paroo, paroo, paroo.
Oh, there she is!
There's Ollie.
That's not Ollie.
Okay, that's all of them after this.
Cute, cute, very rosin.
Lemonade!
Oh, nope, nope, just kidding, sorry.
I almost missed some people.
Hello.
Is this a horror?
Horror bento.
What could be in there?
Heizuki.
Oh, it makes me want some.
Oh, what?
Wait, we did see this guy.
Is he the old man, you think?
Is he the old man that we talked to earlier?
Maybe.
Cat.
Okay.
Very good.
Glad we could see all of those.
He's running.
Wait, oh, is he running for parliament?
oh my gosh I was gonna say that'd be so crazy to see an
actual politician in my video game oh wait we missed these
ones I think oh no just kidding I remember the rainbow ice
okay you on the next one okay I will I will I will um
subscribe to the patreon um like I well I was gonna say
right starving my my my stomach is like i'm hungry ghost
right now i'm hungry ghost um so i'm gonna go haunt some of
your guys's houses please leave out some some snacks for me
to nibble on i'm gonna like house hop and uh you know just
some like some offerings for me no not cookies i'm looking
for something with a little bit more substance probably yeah
i would like some offerings um Sorry, I would talk
afterwards, but my stomach is actually getting upset.
I can't tell if it's upset because I'm hungry or if it's
upset.
Upset.
I don't know.
Tummy heart.
I'm so sorry.
A sandwich.
Yeah, a sandwich would be perfect.
Oh my gosh.
When I was in Japan, I lived off of eggy sandwiches.
I love the ones.
Okay, there would be like egg sandwiches with cucumber and
ham in them.
Oh, it was, oh my gosh, it was so delicious.
Because it was just the right amount.
I don't like a lot.
of ham it was just the right amount of ham for me and i like
a lot of cucumber unfortunately it was kind of slacking i'll
be honest kind of slacking on the on the uh cucumber but
that's okay i could still taste it a little bit i have left
out some durian for you
maybe i won't go to your house kinky that cadaver i just had
some spaghetti no reason what do you mean no reason it was
super obvious but the plant car was the coolest thing i've
seen in these types of games yeah it was really cool it like
felt um oh my gosh you guys know that game tokyo jungle it
felt very much like that maybe maybe i can play that tokyo
jungle that's a fun game i don't know if i've seen anyone
ever stream that one it's kind of older though wild
pomeranians yeah give me tokyo jungle oh gosh face dummy
okay it just all all of a sudden started hurting so luckily
i was able to get through the game i was hungry earlier but
now it's starting to hurt so i am going to end it early i'm
sorry guys i don't mean to end it early but i'm gonna go i'm
gonna call it here thank you guys for hanging out with me
today and um yeah uh thanks for the stream thank you go eat
ghost girl i will
ghost.
Otsuminto!
I will see you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I do what I did totally intend on sticking around and
talking, especially because this is only two and a half
hours, but at least we got... I assume we got all the
endings, right?
I'm assuming that there's only two endings, right?
We got all of them, I think.
It's okay.
Thank you guys for understanding.
I'm gonna go get food.
Otsaminta, Otsaminta.
Yeah?
Yep, just two endings.
Oh, we didn't get caught!
Oh, no!
There's no more?
I can't tell what you guys are saying.
Cool.
Get out of here.
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Bye-bye!
Otsaminta!
Otsumito, Otsumito, Otsumito, Otsumito, Otsumito, Otsumito,
Otsumito thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
thank you, thank you, Thanks for the stream.
You want this tub of chocolate mint ice cream?
Sure!
Thanks for the fun stream.
At least the tummy horde can't kill you again.
So true!
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
Thank y'all.
Nyan y'all.
Mervy.
David, I can't hear you.
Okay.
What's the main tower?
Sayya?
Light.
When I see you.
Next stream is...
Who's so gay?
Okay.
Yuppie!
Bye bye!